zuerst aber nach münchen denn mit einem
fahndungsfoto sucht die polizei jetzt
nach dem mutmaßlichen täter
nach einem radunfall der sich ereignet
hat
der radfahrer fabio de ist dort
gestorben nachdem er sich in einen
streit mit eben wahrscheinlich diesem
fahrradfahrer begeben hatte für die
familie von fabio de ist eine welt
zusammengebrochen hier jetzt noch einmal
die ganze traurige geschichte dieser
fall macht einfach nur wütend
am sonntag kommt es in münchen zu einem
streit zwischen zwei radfahrern einer
davon fabio die hier links im bild kurz
zuvor fuhren beide männer einige meter
nebeneinander
es kam zu einem wortwechsel zeugen
wollen gesehen haben wie dieser mann
fabio de umgestoßen und liegen gelassen
hat ich bin gewarnt man spar gestorben
dieser mensch hat durch den sturz erlitt
der 37 jährige einen milzriss verblutete
innerlich
trotz wiederbelebungsversuchen stirbt er
noch auf der straße
seine familie steht seitdem unter schock
jetzt sind wir momentan einige masse
sage immer so gut obwohl ich noch daran
denken wie mein sohn gestorben ist auf
diese art und weise hat keiner für wings
for zu sterben
besonders tragisch fabio di sollte in
sechs monaten vater werden seine frau
erwartet zwillinge
mit tränen in den augen wendet sie sich
an den flüchtigen täter bitte stellen
sie sich mit ich bitte sie einfach nur
bitte stellen sie sich der polizei
bitte mit diesen aufnahmen fahndet die
polizei nach dem rad rambo die aufnahme
stammt von einem video das am tatort
aufgenommen wurde
gesucht wird dieser radfahrer männlich
40 bis 50 jahre alt 1 70 bis 1 80 groß
stämmig er hat kurze graumelierte haare
und trägt eine kurze blaue hose ein
blaues shirt mit weißen ärmeln
dunkle schuhe sowie einen schwarzen
rucksack einen helm hat er nicht auf
sein fahrrad ist schwarz mit weißen
applikationen
hinweise zum täter geben sie bitte an
die polizei und direkt am tatort in
münchen steht jetzt unser bild reporter
kalk ein paar jetzt gibt es dieses
fahndungsfoto weiß wie groß die resonanz
bisher ist seitdem diese bilder
veröffentlicht wurden sind sehr sehr
viele anrufe bei der polizei in münchen
eingegangen
der großteil davon sind
beileidsbekundungen und wie man der
familie helfen kann
derzeit arbeitet die polizei aber zehn
ernstere hinweise ab die zur ergreifung
des täters führen könnten
der entscheidende hinweis ist aber noch
nicht dabei ist soll nach unserer
information kein hinweis eingegangen
sein der die person konkret mit namen
beschreibt um wo er wohnen könnte
hattest du jetzt noch mal kontakt zu der
familie des verstorbenen wie geht es
ihnen heute
also ich bin im ständigen kontakt mit
der familie gerade mit dem schlager und
mit dem vater und sein schwager wie
haben sie das gesehen im video der
appelliert an diesen unfallfahrer bitte
stell dich der polizei und auch die frau
sagte
bitte stellen sich sie haben mir das
liebste genommen die familie dankt den
medien sehr und auch gerade bild das wir
so offen über diesen fall berichtet und
auch so groß deswegen auch hier nochmal
der hinweis alle die etwas gesehen haben
sollen sich bitte bei der polizei
münchen melden
vielen dank kaka in münchen und
natürlich hoffen wir dass es jetzt
schnellstmöglich zu einem hinweis kommt
der dann zur ergreifung des täters führt